so take a look at our studio audience
yep
not a soul completely empty why is that
it's not because I had two burritos for
lunch it's because we don't want to risk
the health of our awesome awesome fans
now other shows are doing similar things
The Daily Show Samantha bee Seth Meyers
they're also going without an audience
but hey they're used to it see that's
where an audience would laugh but you
can't hear it cuz they're not here in
this studio but it feels good to laugh
someone has to or the virus has won so
let's see where we stand
some people are freaking out going to
Costco and buy in cases of toilet paper
I don't get this reflux when I panic I
don't think about how I'm gonna wipe my
ass an Australian family and their
panicky haste placed an order online for
48 toilet paper rolls but then they hit
the wrong button and ended up with 48
boxes or over two thousand rolls that's
enough to TP the Taj Mahal according to
the dad it'll take him 12 years to use
up all that toilet paper unless they're
like our media who are really full of
crap I wonder is this trumps Katrina
hostage crisis or Chernobyl this may be
Donald Trump's Katrina yeah an incumbent
lost to a Republican challenger because
of an exigency going on late in his term
the taking of American hostages people
said this is Chyna's true noble actually
it's Donald Trump's Chernobyl
makes you wonder are they engaging in
wishful thinking due to an emotional
investment in their hatred for Trump yes
I hope it's not contagious but if it
were they'd blame the president fact is
you can't trust people dripping in
political bias these are people after
all who chased impeachment as the corona
virus spread in China watch Don Lemon
flip out on John Kasich who doesn't like
Trump but refuses to follow Don's script
i watch the address tonight and i
thought it was fine we need straight
you know nation from this president here
on this administration and we're not
getting it and I don't understand why
you are tiptoeing around it that's why
you're here John because we're here to
talk about weight you were here I don't
want you I don't want you to go on and
deflect and talk about something else
so John did dance to Dawn's tune and so
dawn acted like a bank robber who found
out his getaway driver just took him
straight to the police station then
there's this clown who says calling it a
foreign virus is racist the president
referred to the corona virus as a quote
foreign virus why the president would go
as far as to describe it as a foreign
virus that is something we'll also be
asking questions about it's going to
come across to a lot of Americans as
smacking of xenophobia
so I guess zika ebola and Rocky Mountain
fever are racist to all named after
places of origin
Acosta's idiotic emotional bias should
be called CNN virus named after its
origin but I don't have time for this
and frankly neither do you
you're either a plus or a minus and
those are all minuses the pluses we're
now canceling events even a conference
on the corona virus was canceled because
of the corona virus that's like
canceling my fan club meeting because
I'm too hot the NBA postponed their
season but it's not just basketball it's
baseball and hockey too let's go to ESPN
to see what they're showing now let's go
down here
I prefer that programming more now the
Houston Rodeo was also postponed and I
was planning on going so it turns out it
won't be my first rodeo after all yeah I
admit that's a pretty terrible joke but
I couldn't cut it out
but we must cancel events you got a self
distance and avoid large groups finally
the world has caught up with me
a misanthrope my entire life is about
self distancing I mean I've been doing
this show for five years and I still
have to write down the names of my
co-hosts now postponing the Gutfeld
monologues because of the virus we're
moving into the fall because again it's
about you the fans being safe they
postponed Coachella which means
somewhere in the United States there are
75 mediocre bands unpacking their bonds
and let's not forget the Wienermobile
they canceled their events too what will
I do with my buns well I do have a case
of toilet paper meanwhile the stock
market reacts to fear and gossip then
the next day it wakes up hungover and
corrects itself it's up and down and up
and down it's like you're dating a Lohan
but it's a living organism reacting to
its fears of the unknown that's a real
problem or human our fear exists because
we're living in a cloud of unknowns and
fear fills that empty space where facts
should be and that can create panic but
panic in formation becomes control than
preparation and that's good so you have
a war of perspectives on one hand you
have people putting the death risk in
context by comparing it to other killers
like cancer and heart disease but there
are other people who flag this viruses
fast spread which must be slowed so
hospitals can feel the incoming sick
instead of rationing care these
perspectives can both be right but the
second one is the one that really
matters because it enables action true
in a few months we may look back and
think wow we really overdid it we're
such fools but I'm okay with being that
fool and so should you now how important
is the president in all this well he's
got to be forceful in action with
she's been he's also staying out of the
way so the experts could do their jobs
but because he can't vanquish a virus he
can only prepare for it and avoid it
until it leaves and Trump struggles for
words for that but to its credit he's
found the deeds closing the border
bought us time for effective measures
and also mistakes without a head start
in a robust economy the testing mess
could have been devastating let's hope
it won't end up that way but it's wrong
to compare this to a past flu because we
don't know where this could end up it's
like comparing last year's Super Bowl to
next year's crucial info is missing the
future a better comparison 9/11 terror
like a virus was already here and it
mutates to survive it's invisible its
goals get past your defenses undetected
and it creates a fear because it's out
of your control the good news you can
gain control by doing productive things
first realize that we're all in this
together even washing your hands and
self distancing reduces risk for
everyone staying in checking on your
older relatives exercising at home these
acts are important more important than
you realize you're reducing vectors of
transmission you save lives simply by
staying in and that is fantastic just
watching this show at home
reduces risk of disease note this
doesn't work with other shows especially
Jesse's the bright side these behaviors
may reduce overall fatality of other
viruses and yeah we could tell you some
more good news just to make you feel
good but it's better to give you
information to do some good ignore minor
differences for the larger similarity
that we're all human and we're a little
scared but we can all reduce the strain
by contributing what we can to the
shared effort because this is a big war
against the tiniest of things it's
invisible you don't know if it's there
or not but you know where you are and
what you can do and knowing that alone
will make you a hero in a world where we
could use a few more
it's claps right let's welcome tonight's
guests she's the lady with the draw
who's always ready to brawl Fox Business
Network anchor Daggett McDowell he's so
sharp he can't hold a balloon TV
writer/producer Rob long she's ad brainy
and sometimes can complain t hosts if
sincerely count on Fox Nation captive
and he can kill you with his eyebrow in
four tyrants former CIA operative and
host of the upcoming series black files
Declassified oh my god I'm on Science
Channel like Baker yes doing the great
thing about not having an audience I
don't feel bad when somebody gets more
applause you know what I mean like you
like somebody will Michael it might like
taken more than Mike and then Mike at
the end it feels really bad I do yeah he
goes fragile even during times of great
great misery he is more worried about
how much applause he gets because I
can't pander yeah Hillary Clinton right
yes and then every if you want yeah it's
true
you know whenever you land a joke that
they don't like all you have to do is
say but what about Hillary you get so
much so taken you are the business mind
here I have so many questions two of
them are one why do we keep showing the
Dow ticker because I think that that is
like it's like watching a slow-rolling
disaster it's I turn it off get it off
the screen for a few hours I might be
wrong and also what we closed down the
stock market for seven days after six or
seven days this is September 17th what
what's the reason not to do this year
that was some structural problems
actually down in lower Manhattan after
the terror attacks but you can't shut
the markets down because you're
literally just hiding what is really
going on in the market right more you
know again it's just like the virus the
more you know the better because if you
shut it down then you have kaboom right
the apocalypse after you reopen it if
the news is bad but what if you know I
look at the stock market as kind of a
drunk guy at the blackjack table who's
losing I'm his best friend going let's
go into the buffet for a few hours
that's all I want
no not that easy that sound investment
advice this is Vegas the buffet is I
don't know what drink buffets at this
point is a toxic Center sneeze guards
are not yet do you think though the
market was so overvalued anyway outside
of the virus that this downdraft you've
got what ten trillion dollars in debt on
corporate balance sheets in the last
decade so there were a lot of problems
that were building anyway interesting
and so this virus takes off and then you
have the oil price war right so the
washout that you're seeing is creating
this sense of panic panic baguettes
panic fear baguettes fear and you have
lunatics basically it could get worse
for the economy because of what's going
on in the markets just like I went into
a Whole Foods in the last week yeah and
you start you see the the shelves are
all cleared out and I'm grabbing like
Brazil nuts radishes
Zil nuts and radishes and I realized
this is the crap leftover at the worst
part of Christmas party I think that's a
great Food Channel show you go into as
you call it not a whole lot of foods you
know hey Rob are you panicked do you
think it's wise to over prepare and be
and be relieved look uh two-thirds of
what they're telling us to do frankly we
should have been doing anyway exactly
like Japan just live in a hurricane area
you live in a tornado area you live in a
snow emergency area you live in the west
coast we have earthquakes you should
have 72 hours of water 72 hours of
speech canned food you should be
prepared two years of toilet paper I'm
not saying I am well depends if you go
to Arby's a lot you'd say you should you
should but look we all have to you were
right you're mono you're right we all
have to sacrifice a little bit you don't
clearly just you buy your outfit have
sacrifice your performance in moment
Sean's but preparedness is look look
I've said this before the benefit of
this experience now is that we're being
we're training ourselves to prepare for
the next one right there they are going
to keep coming this is the way the world
works
wait you're saying Rob you say we're
going to learn from a past wouldn't it
be great if we did and we and everybody
sort of prepared for this we look look
profits will go down corporates be down
in the second quarter we know that yeah
we're gonna stop business activity for
two weeks almost three weeks so the more
maybe it hit that's something I gotta
have to pay for and in the long game of
things it's not really that much yeah
economy's great the country's in great
shape the world is in good shape I like
you just got to stay home for two it I
like that you said that I I know cat you
had a shutdown you're a singing telegram
service I know the thing is preparedness
is one thing but like there's nothing on
the shelves in so many places and the
hand sanitizer hoarding in the so
porting it does it make sense me and
everyone always says oh you're so
selfish to not wash you're like to hoard
all this stuff and yourself is not
thinking of others but like that's true
but you're also not thinking of yourself
because it also benefits you if the
other people and your community are
washing their hands squeezing lemon
juice on their hands so they go to the
bathroom because there's no soap left I
mean while you're pouring it all over
your slip-and-slide in your backyard or
whatever you're doing with that much
nervous about it you want some Purell
I'll sell you some 4/16 okay I know
where you guys I've been there
you know I know you live out here sure I
just mentioned just mention a couple of
things that I'm kind of jinx the great
state Idaho but no reported cases yet
but I think there's something more to it
in the fact that you go and nobody's
panicking at least an eye potatoes we
got a lot of the trout yes and got a
trout there too we got guns are in your
bed Mike no it's a walk-in safe kids
around
although although you know scooters
don't as hunting certificate so he's
good to go
but anyway the point being is is is the
shelves are full we're not seeing the
same sort of thing that you may be
seeing it's other urban areas and part
of that is because of the number of
cases that may be happening but III
think there's a big big difference
between being realistic pragmatic and
prepared and panic but that's my point
is you give into the panic a rational
person if you're surrounded by lunatics
becomes a lunatic for you like my
radishes and my Brazil I couldn't find
toilet paper and I was having an anxiety
attack and I called a friend of mine and
I said I don't have toilet paper and
they went wash your butt yeah there you
go by the way we have to move on but
there are alternatives to toilet paper
you know you have Kleenex
yeah the New York Times corncobs batch
the media corn cob corn in the old days
they do a Frontier Days yeah you got to
be really careful with the corn cob
wasn't your rank colonel you read it
don't go anywhere be right back